mais là on habitait alors tout le monde
se demande si je vais te poser la
question fatidique mais juste avant est
ce que tu te rappelles en septembre tpm
je voudrais te rappeler des bons
souvenirs
tu as eu beaucoup de déguisements
regarde la fête populaire garantit ses
mots de la rédaction de télé 7 jours
nous
vous
j'ai eu des moments de doute je marchais
sans savoir vers où je ne
notre truc
est-ce que tu rappelles de mon image
préférée avec jean luc lemoine dans les
quatre tiers cet échange exceptionnelle
entre deauville et terry c'est quoi le
coup de fil il appelle qui regardent et
nous est acquis pour passer dans l'autre
camp cyril vous a fait quiconque
l'astronaute comme ça [ __ ] l'équipe en
face moi l'autre qu'on ne sait rien
derrière l'autre
nice a réagi
vous appelez qui pour pascal autres
combats ont éclaté lorsque la pause je
rappelle que demain on sera là en direct
bien sûr tous ensemble on aura raquel
garrido qui leur à nouveau sa to say we
raquel garrido on l'attend depuis
longtemps elle donnera nous voir elle a
accepté notre invitation titi c'est koné
la question devait être posée est-ce que
voilà tu aurais envie de revenir
quelques fois comme ça dans tpm peu ou
pas du tout alors j'ai rien contre le
principe parce que d'abord manqué tous
beaucoup
le seul problème c'est que je fais
d'autres très tôt il ya la matinale
alors où il ya des pmp je prépare en
général la matinale du matin donc soit
j'étais en matinale soit je prépare ce
lendemain j'ai des projets je travaille
sur une série documentaire que je suis
en train de voir des producteurs donc ça
serait compliqué en termes d'horaires
après c'est une question d'argent
si j'arrive à avoir un énorme viendra
pas
bien